gabe
sweet aaron i'm throwing the halloween
party and i just want to amp it up a
little i think it could use some
extra pizzazz okay where'd escape factor
in remember that halloween party you
took me to once the one where i i
started crying as soon as i walked in
and
i didn't stop crying yes
lars and tacos okay well let's say that
i wanted this party to be a tiny
tiny bit like that one
just
more adult more more scary and sexy i
will make this sexier than you could
ever imagine it was just scary if we
wanted ideas for scary stuff
[Applause]
oh that'd be scary what are you thinking
all right let me go get it
um okay
everybody
be
prepared to be scared
okay
[Music]
the cinema of the unsettling is a
growing film movement
the most well-known film in the genre is
an hour-long shot of a squirrel with
diarrhea
[Music]
is that my grandmother
what's the story there is no story yeah
it seems like there isn't a narrative
maybe the filmmaker realized that even
narrative is comforting
[Music]
what the hell is going on here okay i
think we've seen enough you can turn it
off now yeah
where is this from that is so upsetting
that was awful robert i apologize i'm
sorry i got confused i heard that you
wanted to make the party more adult but
i think i know what to do now this game
is called
pecker poker
it's the game of cards that gets you
hard
you